vaivén quiere dejar su mensaje claro
we'll be the kid se lo seguiremos
diciendo seguiremos enfatizando que la
frontera no está abierta que devuelven a
la mayoría de gente no logran entrar a
eeuu y francamente el mensaje no es no
vengan ahora es no vengan así nunca
hartnett esto
en esta no es la manera de entrar a eeuu
la manera de entrar al país es hacerlo
de manera legal pero para muchos no es
posible y viajan hasta la frontera entre
méxico y eeuu esperanzados por la nueva
administración demócrata que prometió
una política migratoria más humanizada y
revirtió las medidas más duras que había
impuesto su predecesor donald trump
después de una caída drástica en el
número de llegadas provocada en abril
por la pandemia la cifra de migrantes
detenidos en la frontera sur de eeuu no
ha dejado de aumentar el mayor salto con
diferencia es entre enero y febrero de
este año un aumento de un 28% en los
meses de transición entre la
administración trump y bailén aunque los
adultos solos siguen siendo los que más
tratan de cruzar la frontera la llegada
de menores no acompañados ha aumentado
un 61 4% y la de las familias un 163 9%
la mayoría son mexicanos pero en febrero
casi se duplicó el número de hondureños
guatemaltecos y salvadoreños que
llegaron a la frontera sin embargo para
estos migrantes indocumentados la
esperanza del gobierno de bailén es
falsa bajo el argumento de la crisis
sanitaria la enorme mayoría son
regresados a méxico - los menores no
acompañados
y no noticiaron que venimos para acá en
ningún momento ni firmamos deportaciones
ni nada
una crisis cada vez de mayores
dimensiones que ensombrece las reformas
migratorias de bailén